fan tribüne feiern stadion hopping
welche rolle spielt die em bei der
verbreitung der korona delta variante in
europa isoliert abgeschottet und
trotzdem viel zu oft infiziert welche
lehren die pflege aus der pandemie
ziehen muss und es hat gekracht gestürmt
und ganz viel geregnet im südwesten
schlugen schwere unwetter brachial zu
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers umarmt ihn ein
willkommen bei uns um 7 christian guckt
auf den sport und heute natürlich auch
auf deutschland gegen england genau es
geht um alles oder nichts später mehr
genannt und wir beginnen auch mit der em
aber unter einem anderen aspekt einem
der politikern in deutschland jetzt
sorgen macht eine europameisterschaft
quer über den ganzen kontinent mit
vielen reisenden fans und mitunter sehr
vollen stadien und gleichzeitig eine
variante des virus die sich offenbar
immer weiter durchsetzt julia schröter
das wembley-stadion dicht besetzt 45.000
überwiegend englische fans sind vor ort
bei den halbfinals und dem endspiel
dürfen sogar 60.000 ins stadion
viel zu viele kritisieren politiker aus
deutschland
die inzidenz in großbritannien liegt
aktuell bei rund 170 ich halte es für
unverantwortlich wenn in ländern die als
virusvarianten gebiet der
hochansteckenden delta mutation gelten
zigtausende menschen auf engem raum
zusammenkommen zu großen nähe in wembley
und anderen stadien kommen die an- und
abreisen und die fans feiern
auch in deutschland abstandsregeln
geraten da schnell in den hintergrund
man muss natürlich auch schauen dass
hier entsprechend unter einigermaßen die
hygienischen bedingungen auch gefeiert
wird es gibt natürlich auch papi wie es
gibt entsprechende zusammenkünfte man
sollte sich eben immer noch im
hinterkopf behalten corona ist nicht weg
corona nicht weg die delta variante auf
dem vormarsch rki-chef wiler wird aus
einer sitzung mit den
landesgesundheitsminister zitiert delta
machen und 35 prozent aller infektionen
aus tatsächlich müsse der anteil sogar
auf 50 prozent geschätzt werden weil die
daten immer einige tage alt sein
dieser entwicklung begegnet deutschland
mit strengen einreise regeln ab sofort
gelten auch portugal und russland als
virusvarianten gebiet rückreisende von
dort auch geimpfte müssen nun für 14
tage in quarantäne
deutschland habe die strengsten regeln
in europa sagt der kanzleramtschef unser
schwachpunkt ist dass andere länder in
europa die nicht auch haben so dass also
auch einträge über
händler und anderes immer wieder möglich
sind und da sind wir hoch alarmiert der
kampf gegen die delta variante läuft die
sommerferien und die em machen ihn nicht
leichter besonders russland macht die
delta variante schwer zu schaffen lange
taten sie dort so als sei kohona schon
überstanden
das scheint sich jetzt zu rechnen vor
allem in sankt petersburg und in moskau
explodieren die fallzahlen rund 90
prozent davon sollen auf delta
zurückgehen und landesweit wurden
gestern 652 tote registriert so viele
wie noch nie an einem tag seit beginn
der pandemie auch weil die impfstrategie
nicht aufgeht zwar gibt es jede menge
impfstoff aber die skepsis in der
bevölkerung ist groß etwa 85 prozent der
russinnen und russen haben keine impfung
axel sturm berichtet es ist auch in
russland nur ein kleiner pieks aber
einer der lange von der mehrheit
abgelehnt wurde
diese im station gerade neu eröffnet
einem er in einer zwölf millionen
metropole in der es bereits gut fünf
dutzend solcher einrichtungen gibt
die lage in moskau bleibt extrem
schwierig die zahl der
krankenhauseinweisungen ist gestiegen
inzwischen sind fast 15.000 betten
belegt das ist eine hohe zahl data tötet
immer mehr menschen in russland heute
wieder ein trauriger rekord 121
menschenleben verloren an das virus nur
in moskau in nur 24 stunden
inzwischen gibt es sie die schlangen vor
den im stationen das aber liegt
vermutlich am druck aus der politik
jetzt nämlich impfpflicht im
dienstleistungsbereich home office
pflicht für viele angestellte masken und
handschuh pflicht rein theoretisch in
geschlossenen räumen viele bürger
bleiben skeptisch
diese impfstoffe sind nicht ausreichend
getestet es ist zu früh sich impfen zu
lassen
in den nachrichten sieht man dass
konzerte stattfinden
da fragt man sich was eigentlich wollen
die behörden
welches ziel verfolgen sie
ein rockfestival am wochenende in leach
pads eine schulabschlussfeier in sankt
petersburg viel lebensfreude wenig
abstand dafür ab sofort strengere regeln
beim zugang zu bars und restaurants nur
wer geimpft gewesen oder getestet ist da
frei klar ist russlands corona politik
wirft fragen auf und der russische weg
der pandemie bekämpfung war bislang
nicht erfolgreich um vor gefahren zu
schützen dürfe es auf keinen fall noch
einmal zur isolation alter
pflegebedürftiger menschen kommen
das ist ein kernsatz aus dem aktuellen
aok pflegereport er schaut auf einen
corona jahr zurück und liefert
bedrückende daten und erkenntnisse
so gab es in pflegeheimen dramatisch
mehr tote und die besuchs sperren für
angehörige belasteten bewohnerinnen und
bewohner schwer sylvia bleßmann
berichtet isolation und einsamkeit sind
vorbei denn der erreichte impfschutz
gibt allen hier ein stück normalität
zurück nach quälend langer zeit von
körperlicher distanz und angst vor
ansteckung alle haben ein stück
menschenwürde zurück erlangt das glück
zu einer gemeinschaft zu gehören dass
man in gesellschaft es dass man sich
bewegen kann dass ich meine familie habt
dass die mich besuchen können der leiter
des seniorenstifts ist froh dass sie
hier ohne großen infektions ausbruch
durch die pandemie kamen auch wenn die
arbeitsbelastung groß war und das
notwendigste von anfang an fehlte
wir hatten zu beginn der pandemie kein
desinfektionsmittel kein
händedesinfektion ist mir keine
handschuhe keinen mundschutz keine kette
alles das was wir brauchten mussten wir
auch wirklich mühsam wegen besorgen und
das hat denen die den alltag der ohnehin
schon extrem schwer aber noch
problembeladen da gemacht
niedergeschlagenheit antriebslosigkeit
nachlassende geistige fitness waren laut
aok pflege studie folgen der isolation
der report zeigt schonungslos auf dass
die alten menschen extrem abbauten und
auch viel mehr heimbewohner starben
wir erkannten dass die sterblichkeit in
den heimen über 20 prozent höher lag im
jahresvergleich das steigerte sich wenn
wir oktober bis november 2020 anschauen
auf im mittel 30 prozent in spitzen
sogar 80 prozent
hohe infektionsraten auch unter den
pflegenden führten oft zu kleineren
teams arbeitsverdichtung und steigende
psychische belastung anhaltende ängste
um das eigene wohl und die gesundheit
der bewohner stellen die verfasser der
studie fest und fordern dringend mehr
und besser ausgebildetes personal sowie
gute hygiene konzepte für die heime vor
gut einer woche ist das buch jetzt wie
wir unser land erneuern erschienen von
der grünen kanzlerkandidatin annalena
baerbock
jetzt wirft ihr der österreichische
medienwissenschaftler stefan weber vor
passagen abgeschrieben zu haben
die grünen weisen das entschieden zurück
bei dem buch handelt es sich nicht um
einen akademischen text berbalk stellt
auf 240 seiten politische konzepte vor
und verbindet das mit persönlichen
erlebnissen die frage nach berlin unsere
hauptstadt korrespondent in schackenthal
berner dynamik und allah welche
bandbreite haben denn da jetzt die
reaktionen in der politik so vor der
bundestagswahl
ja die ist relativ weit gefächert da
gibt es natürlich diejenigen die auf den
vorwurf anspringen dennoch aufgreifen
dazu gehört zum beispiel markus blume
der csu generalsekretär
der schreibt würde bei twitter da sei
vorsätzlich getäuscht worden schlampig
gearbeitet und hoch gestapelt worden
aber selbst aus den eigenen reihen aus
der hre aus den reihen der konkurrenz zu
den grünen gibt es auch andere stimmen
zum beispiel aus der cdu der
europaparlamentarier dennis radtke der
sagt es gibt doch wichtigeres und zitat
man muss nicht aus jedem furz einen
knall machen und auch die fdp setzt hier
nicht auf attacke marco buschmann der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer hat
getwittert es gibt wichtigeres und jeder
wisse doch dass bücher von
spitzenkandidatinnen spitzenkandidaten
die literarische qualität einer
werbebroschüre hätten also man sieht
dass die enthüllungen hier nicht mit der
wucht einschlagen die man in einem
wahljahr erwarten könnte trotzdem
setzten die grünen jetzt hier auf
maximale verteidigung sprechen
von einem versuchten rufmord und haben
einen star anwalt engagiert der sagt es
gibt überhaupt keine anzeichen für
urheberrechtsverletzungen da sieht man
also eine sehr große politische
nervosität auch wenn man wohl weiß dass
die juristische seite vielleicht zu
handhaben ist aber der politische
schaden sehr viel schwerer zu beheben
ist wenn eine kanzlerkandidatin ein buch
schreibt in dem sie ihre vision kraft
darstellen möchte dann sollten die sätze
wahrscheinlich schon er aus eigener
feder sein
und solche fehler sind wirklich schwer
zu verkraften in einem wahljahr
das kratzt an der authentizität der
kandidatencheck und sabanci in berlin
ich habe unter dankeschön dafür ein kind
ist unbezahlbar klar was ist
durchschnittlich für kosten verursacht
dazu haben die wissenschaftler im
statistischen bundesamt diese rechnung
aufgemacht danach geben eltern jeden
monat 763 euro für ein kind aus für
ältere kinder noch mehr ab einem alter
von zwölf jahren sind es im schnitt
schon 553 euro
dabei gibt es große unterschiede je nach
dem einkommen der familie für bildung zb
geben ärmere eltern im schnitt 28 euro
pro monat aus wohlhabende mit 83 euro
rund drei mal so viel
und noch eine wichtige zahl plus 2,3
prozent das ist die aktuelle
teuerungsrate für den juni ein leichter
rückgang zum monat mai nach monaten
stetigen anstiegs im jahresvergleich
besonders hoch sind die kosten für
energie ebenfalls deutlich teurer
restaurantbesuche übernachtungen und
kleidung
trotz sorgen vor dem was noch kommen
könnte aktuell sinken die korona zahlen
und die wirtschaft atmet auf auch im
osten von deutschland
und so blicken dort laut ifo
geschäftsklimaindex besonders der handel
und verarbeitende unternehmen
optimistisch in die zukunft
die gastronomie ebenfalls sie hat
allerdings ein problem kneipen cafés und
co dürfen wieder öffnen können es
häufiger aber nicht oder nur
eingeschränkt denn es fehlt personal
melanie hug hier im gasthaus zur neu in
jena serviert die chefin selbst das
traditionslokal mit hotel läuft wieder
die betreiber sind zufrieden
nur eines fehlt das personal wir haben
aktuell noch für auszubildende zwei
stellen offen und verbrauchen küche
stellen wir gerne ein frühstücks dame
suchen war und im housekeeping gleich
das wären 80 prozent auslastung hat ihr
hotel wieder die branche im aufwind
doch in der zeit des lok downs haben
sich viele gerade im
dienstleistungssektor andere jobs
gesucht beim hotel- und
gaststättenverband thüringen melden nun
betriebe personallücken es brauche mehr
als offene türen
seit november haben wir den betrieben
die am objektiv nicht ausbilden konnten
die ausbildung abgenommen hatten hier
teilweise 350 auszubilden im haus in
zwei anderen objekten hat eine
jugendherberge angemietet damit die
jungen leute unterbringen konnten
damit wir eine perspektive bieten damit
wird die jungen leute behalten
im gasthaus und hotel zur noll versuchen
sie die arbeitsstunden des personals in
grenzen zu halten und sie überlegen
weniger geburtstags oder vereinsfeiern
anzunehmen
natürlich auch versuchen wir auch mit
mehr löhnen und mit höheren löhnen
entgegenzusteuern
im moment haben sie die küche nicht
durchgehend besetzt und die
öffnungszeiten eingeschränkt daran
werden sich die gäste vor erst gewöhnen
müssen
kleine korrektur zu den zahlen des
statistischen bundesamtes vorhin in der
sendung da habe ich eine falsche zahl
genannt
eltern geben im schnitt für kinder ab
zwölf jahre 953 euro im monat aus das
ist eine jetzt die richtige zahl und auf
der grafik haben sie auch die richtige
zeit schon lesen können jetzt unser
nächstes thema heftige gewitter mit
starkregen und hagel so nennen
meteorologen die wetterlage die seit
gestern in teilen deutschlands große
schäden verursacht hat von sturmböen und
schweren niederschlägen betroffen waren
viele regionen einige unwetter zogen in
richtung osten ab andere bildeten sich
neu vor allem in baden württemberg gehen
die aufräumarbeiten weiter simon
pfanzelt es zieht über den südwesten
deutschlands hinweg und hinterlässt
vielerorts chaos
die straßen überflutet wie hier im kreis
rottweil die einen fahren einfach durch
die anderen versuchen das wasser aus dem
weg zu schaffen irgendwie
im moment kurzzeitig machtlos gegen
diese wasser und mengen und massen in
der stuttgarter innenstadt führt der
starkregen zu verkehrschaos
kulis laufen voll autos stecken fest
allein hier muss die feuerwehr zu über
330 einsätzen ausrücken
einer davon an der stuttgarter
staatsoper teile vom dach sind hier
abgerissen und eine statue
heruntergestürzt
das alles während laufender
veranstaltungen mit 250 gästen verletzt
wird niemand
auch in hessen und rheinland-pfalz
heftige gewitter und überflutete straßen
etwa in koblenz kamen bender versucht
die apotheke vor dem fall laufen zu
bewahren
handtücher türen zugemacht und
versichern
hier in reutlingen macht das unwetter
den fußballabend zunichte hier in einem
partykeller steht das wasser und kommt
rein direkt durchs fenster weil wir
einfach hier einen starken sturm haben
und auch heute macht das wetter probleme
in waiblingen fällt ein baum auf einen
vorbeifahrenden pkw
die fahrerin wird offenbar schwer
verletzt sie und ihre beiden kleinen
kinder müssen ins krankenhaus gebracht
werden
in stuttgart laufen derweil die
aufräumarbeiten während sich vielerorts
weitere gewitter zusammenbrauen
ganz anders sieht es im westen der usa
und von kanada aus trockenheit und eine
hitze wie sie so noch nie gemessen wurde
in der kanadischen provinz british
columbia jeden tag neue
temperaturrekorde zuletzt 47,9 grad
geschäfte schulen und impfzentren wurden
geschlossen auch im us-staat oregon
waren es mehr als 46 grad die behörden
stellen klimatisierte räume zur
verfügung und hitze soll noch einige
tage dauern sehr belastend für mensch
und tier
und dann sind wir beim sport christian
und gucken auf das spiel natürlich in
wembley spannend ausgeglichen aber noch
null zu null vielleicht wird seiner
spannender von wahnsinn wird nach dem
gestrigen achtelfinale in bukarest
gesprochen als außenseiter schweiz trotz
1 3 rückstand das spiel gegen den
weltmeister tatsächlich noch drehte und
im elfmeterschießen frankreich das
turnier ende bescherte regenwetter in
paris am tag nach dem deprimierenden
em-aus des weltmeisters von der
desillusion ja der vernichtung schreibt
frankreichs presse
ich habe nicht das gefühl dass die
mannschaft wirklich alles gegeben habe
alles gegeben haben in bukarest aber die
eidgenossen die fähre wind brachte den
außenseiter überraschend in führung
nachdem rodrigues das 2 0 für die
schweiz verpasste schlug frankreich
zurück und zog durch dieses traumtor von
top 3 zu 1
der kampfgeist der schweiz aber
ungebrochen erste fähre witsch und dann
gavranovic treffen zum 33
nach einer torlosen verlängerung und
neun verwandelten elfmetern
der große showdown kilian np gegen yann
sommer schon unglaubliche fußballabend
finde ich werde mir sehr viel moral
gezeigt sehr viel herz herz und moral
bei dieser em ein erfolgsrezept das der
schweiz den weg geebnet hat ins
viertelfinale am freitag gegen spanien
unglaublich erfolgreicher auftakt spiele
für deutschlands beste tennis profis
beim dritten grand-slam-turnier des
jahres auf dem rasen von wimbledon
angelique kerber setzte sich in zwei
sätzen mit 6 4 und 6 3 gegen die serbin
nina stojanovic durch und ebenfalls
souverän weiter alexanders wert gleich
in seinem ersten match in wimbledon hat
der hamburger mit dem typisch britischen
regenwetter zu kämpfen als er nach
mehreren spielunterbrechungen nässe
bedingt ausrutscht rollt er seinen sturz
gekonnt ab und kann mit dieser szene die
schließung des daches erwirken
nach von da an sturz freien spiel
gewinnt alexander zverev gegen den
niederländischen qualifikanten zahlen
kriegs bau glatt in drei sätzen und darf
für sein zweitrundenmatch am donnerstag
nun auf trockenere swyn bilden wetter
hoffen
[Applaus]
und noch zur tour de france vierter der
treppe die mit einem streik der fahrer
begann wegen der vielen stürze durch
mangelnde sicherheitsmaßnahmen
tagessieger massensprint nach gut 150
kilometern in der mark cavendish der
insgesamt 31 etappen erfolg für den
briten nur eddy merckx aus belgien war
mit 34 bisher besser und in der
gesamtwertung keine veränderung da mehr
tatsächlich unglaubliche bilder gesehen
von der sorte frau christin vielen dank
jetzt noch dass die südfranzösische
stadt arles hat antike bauten zu bieten
einiges aus dem mittelalter und ab jetzt
auch futuristisches eine art spiegelndes
ufo keine seite gleich kein vorne oder
hinten und fast auch kein oben oder
unten ein passendes gebäude für
zeitgenössische kunst durfte
stararchitekt frank gehry entwerfen und
das ist dabei rausgekommen
die kunst ist noch nicht eingezogen aber
alle hat schon mal ein wahrzeichen mehr
wieder gibt es heute abend heftige
unwetter aktuell gelten warnungen für
nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz
hessen und bayern mehr gleich von
präsident ali ich empfehle ich natürlich
das heute journal mit dem kollegen claus
kleber heute um fünf nach 11 23 uhr fünf
von uns danke für ihr interesse gerne
das morgen aber erst in allen ein sehr
angenehmer abend tschüss
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die unwetterserie
der letzten tage
die lässt noch nicht nach weg bekommen
ein neues tief und das zieht ebenfalls
relativ langsam bringt schwitzens morgen
nachmittag dann heftige gewitter von
westen her
wir haben abend gibt es weitere heftige
gewitter
die kommen etwa bis zur mitte voran und
in den osten bayerns und da ist ein
hagelsturm und auch platzregen dabei
teilweise auch andauernder regen ähnlich
sieht es dann auch im nordosten aus in
der nacht zieht das ganze dann noch
weiter in den nordosten 19 bis neun grad
die tiefsten temperaturen uns morgen im
tagesverlauf dann weitere heftige
gewitter erst am vormittag im norden
noch und dann zum nachmittag von westen
her in den östlichen landesteilen vom
erzgebirge bis in den bayerischen wald
gibt es teilweise längere zeit
sonnenschein 25 grad im osten
deutschlands und deutlich kühler im
westen 17 18 teils 19 grad die kommenden
tage am donnerstag noch einmal schauer
und gewitter bei 16 bis 22 grad freitag
wird allmählich wärmer und von südwesten
her trockener samstag dann bis 26 grad
damit ein schöner abend